so good morning my name is Stephan Simon
and I'm the director
preservation of cousin her tits
campus which is seven miles down on the
i-95 and it's my great pleasure to be
here with you on a very hot summer day I
just came here on my bike and I just
thought well that's a that's a hot day
you know but that's New Haven right once
we complain about the cold winter and
then we complain about the hot summer it
still is the greatest small city in
America as many people say today's topic
is about cultural heritage cultural
heritage preservation I call this
sustainable management of change signs
of preserving cultural heritage and I
want to take you on a journey through
what actually cultural heritage is where
we find it I mean far and close to us
how it is under threat where it is under
threat and what we can do to preserve it
actually together so actually yes I mean
what do we consider as cultural heritage
and why should we actually preserve it
why why we have an institute for the
preservation of cultural heritage why
should we preserve it and how and you
already see a few photos and pictures
which will come back during my
presentation this morning well cultural
heritage people think usually about Mona
Lisa about Nefertiti about the high
profile objects of famous collections
like you know the Mona Lisa in the
Louvre in Paris
Nefertiti in Berlin with the national
museums of Germany of course these
objects are famous these objects are
iconic these objects get the interest of
many many visitors look this is how Mona
Lisa is shown in the Louvre hundreds of
people want to have a photo with her
without her and I don't know and and
that was a that is what people usually
understand about cultural heritage
actually most people I would say 90%
think it's about paintings or sculptures
and of course it's also about treasures
like
this one this is probably the most
important reliquary of the Catholic
Church in Cologne Cathedral seen by more
than five million visitors every year
it's the so-called three magic shrine
golden shrine built by Nicholas from
verda Mosin art as it's called with nm
ELLs with gold really very famous with
it with the remains of the three Maji
the three kings well if you believe that
but it's the most important a reliquary
in the Catholic Church this is another
very iconic site the side of Petra and
jordan tomb façades the so called royal
tomb façades it's world heritage since
1985 and of course there are threats
there as well
like collapse of structures erosion due
to flooding rain water drainage and salt
crystallization this woman is very
famous too I would say most of you know
her maybe not in that you know for him
because that is utter from polish that
water from number in number Cathedral a
very famous sculpture you know said to
be the most beautiful Romanesque
sculpture in the German history and was
very popular during the Nazi time many
girls were called Utah you know in these
times because Germany was so you know
proud of their art and and and and yeah
and then came a man in this country
his name was Walt Disney and he wanted
to take revenge on the Germans and the
politics so you will recognize her as
the evil stepmother in the famous movie
by Walt Disney of 1937 and that's not
something I made up
that is what was Disney miraculously
managed so you all know her but you know
her from what isn't he probably not from
an Albert Cathedral but still an
important monument actually we already
see a little bit of scientific
investigation equipment how we look at
her how we investigated which stage she
is
well cultural heritage is also this if
you work in my field you have the luxury
who can fly drones you know very nice
this is the cemetery it's a Jewish
cemetery in in my home country of
Bavaria where we you know document the
state of preservation actually I'm here
standing in the middle of the cemetery
very small with my Yale sweatshirt and
and I think this is also the history
this is the history of of you know
cemeteries where people are buried
families obturate stories are told and
and this belongs to cultural heritage as
much as Mona Lisa and Nefertiti and of
course the big cathedrals of nature like
yeah I am Albert Bierstadt
know German born American artist and the
painting here in the art gallery from
the late 19th century of Yosemite Valley
and Glacier Point Trail the cathedrals
of nature but the cathedrals built by
human beings like the Cologne Cathedral
actually very difficult to make a photo
from Cologne Cathedral because it's so
large where I showed you the three magic
shrine or other cathedrals in this
country one of my most favorite
monuments these are the Watts Towers in
the city of watts in Los Angeles
built by Simon Rodia also some kind of a
cathedral really beautiful a 20th
century construction and you know
historic landmark in the state of
California and of course they are the
real castles real cause of royal castles
like this one interesting but also like
this one in Casa Grande in Arizona a
Native American structure with shelter
on top of it which shall prevent it from
being dissolved by rain and weather and
as much as we have the old castles we
also have the industrial heritage this
is world heritage as well this is the
steel and coal Factory in the in Germany
the hit sulfur iron which is the world
heritage site with all the industrial
remnants of the 19th and 20th history a
century well we can also go down to the
smaller scale we can look at small
objects like photographs this is the
famous photograph by Lewis Hine the
power house mechanic 1920 people pay a
lot of money for this objects if they
collect them and they treasure them and
so they become cultural heritage as and
now I return to - well this may as the
animation cells painted in the 1930s 40s
you know with in in the Walt Disney
Studios and you see if you take a closer
look you see that
you know Cinderella is losing the paint
on her skirt the paint is flaking off
you get cracks Leonardo da Vinci said
with time and water everything changes
and I think that's very true and it
refers to the animation cells it refers
also to audio tapes maybe you are not
familiar with this anymore but many
years ago you know before there were mp3
players people recorded sound on this
kind of tapes and they aged and they
also at some point are not anymore
playable and it goes to the contemporary
art deny I show two photos which I just
saw last weekend at the Daiya in beacon
in New York not far away from here one
hour and a half to drive light
installations by them flavor and light
installation like this one or like this
one very very ephemeral very very short
life just you know contemporary art you
turn on off the electricity and it's out
your impression is gone
you have landscapes whole landscapes
this isn't looks like a simple River
with a simple meadow but it is actually
a World Heritage Site the World Heritage
Site between Germany and Poland
but Moscow created by a prince Hammond
from Moscow in the 1800 20s and 30s and
every tree every you know every plant is
planted according to a certain plan and
is under protection of cultural heritage
farm houses like this one in Georgia
belonged to cultural heritage old
farmhouses but also and you have that
here in New Haven as well this photo is
also from Georgia from Tbilisi is a
collection of Caucasian butterflies
indigenous butterflies but you have 13
million objects here in the Yale Peabody
Museum 13 million objects that's a lot
which belong to the culture heritage to
the preservation of cultural heritage
and need to be preserved from being
eaten by pests from fading by light from
just being lost in a drawer and we have
a lot of intangible heritage also we
have our food traditions we have our
languages our dances our and I showed
this photo because it's from my home
country in Bavaria you know every fall
every September the cows are taken down
from the higher altitude methods Meadows
to the villages where they stay over the
winter people dress in lederhosen I have
the lederhosen - I just thought you know
for today it may be a little bit too
hard to come with leather trousers to
show that I think my Bavarian accent
will do that alone you know you don't
need my lederhosen and my beaver an
outfit for that but going back to New
Haven and to the to New England
you have the Native American languages
you have a Bible in 1663 translated into
upon work language it's in the Pequot
museum not far from here and and you
have a deal even the possibility to
learn Native American languages in the
Native American language project which
is now in its second year and you can
learn like on the right how to play the
Native American game of stickball
so our Institute has a mandate we are
dedicated to advancing the field of
heritage science through dance
transdisciplinary research education
training as
as practice and advocacy or advocacy
with the aim of enhancing sustainable
preservation of cultural heritage
interpretation and access and service to
the global conservation community that
sounds really complicated but you know
maybe the few key words it's about
preservation cultural heritage we have
just heard what that is
it has about it's about research
education and training
it's about sustainability and I will
talk a little bit about that as well
interpretation and excess because those
are the three things in cultural
heritage what is the worth of cultural
heritage if you cannot access it and
what is the value of cultural heritage
if you don't really know what it is so
interpretation is also important so we
have this institute on West Campus it's
a huge building it was once belonging to
the Bayer pharmaceutical German company
the headquarters of North America and
has been remodeled has been re furnished
to become a hub for the collections for
collection storage art galleries out
there the musical instruments are out
the Peabody Museum is out there but we
also have the energy Science Institute
we have the high performing computer
high performance computer center
computing center and we have the IPC H
our small Institute with the beautiful
conservation lab at some point we were
thinking that you might be able to come
and see the conservation lab but well we
I don't know why actually because we
said we was better to be downtown
because it's less complicated with the
commute but that is a view into the
conservation lab which is a large shared
facility where yellow collections
conservatists curators faculty members
work together on analysis on paintings
which is the painting but going down to
to ethnographic objects light
installations here you see somebody
working on and tapas from from the South
Sea and you know in an open space in a
shared environment
he says the tapas and really huge and
unique
one of its kind so maybe at some point
you will have an opportunity to visit
the West Campus and the conservation lab
of the Institute in the future we have
huge studios for photography where
objects are documented your
investigations are made and here I would
like to go into one topic which I
thought might be maybe a special
interest to you which you know we we try
to call CSI not crime scene
investigation but actually conservation
science investigation because that is to
a great extent what we do in this
laboratory we as you can imagine we
cannot take big samples from objects
because the curators would say well that
you destroy my object so it has to be
either non-destructive or Micro invasive
very similar to this one there's only
one difference with where the CSI is
that in this TV series the chemists
analyzes the secret within like 20
seconds in our real life we need like
weeks and months and that leads often to
frustrations because people more and
more get used it's called actually the
CSI effect you watch the series UCR as a
little sample has to be analyzed
Carl Acker bone DNA rarely takes longer
than 20 seconds in the TV but in real
life it still takes weeks and months so
my my first point here is it all starts
with watching carefully and observing
carefully this is the first thing you
don't need a scientist for that you just
need you know yourself see that
so-called Allison just gave you have to
fills the a a field and the B field do
you think they are the same in color or
do you think they're different they're
the same yes very good there are exactly
the same they don't look as if they were
the same but they are the same because
this is Adelson game it shows you that
sometimes what you see in the first
glance
is not necessarily the truth the other
thing which I would like to show is the
lilac chaser just focus on the little
black cross in the middle of this game
and just watch this cross so what
happens is if you watch it longer all
this magenta circles disappear and you
have a green circle running around right
is it true
can you see that but there is no green
circle only thing which happens is that
they are fading out one of the magenta
circles and going around it just what
you actually have is a gray circle
instead of a magenta one and you see the
complementary picture this is one of the
games which I like to show because you
know when it's about CSI and the museum
when it's about finding out about
forgeries and fakes and art objects you
can never trust what you see in the
first place because Rajas and and people
who want to sell paintings for millions
of dollars
which are not originals which are not
authentic they do a lot to cheat you and
that you see things which which are not
really there for example a famous
example of a forgery is this photo may
be have seen that before it's an iconic
photo it's time symbolizes the end of
the Second World War a Russian soldiers
Soviet soldiers are putting up the
Soviet Union flag on the high stock the
Parliament in Berlin you see the city is
in smoke and fire you also see a soldier
climbing up and another soldier holding
him that he's not falling down it's an
iconic form the real photo which was
base of this photo is actually this one
if you take a closer look it's a little
bit different right from this one so if
it took a closer look you see that the
soldier who is holding
and you know the leg of the other
soldier look at his two hands and his
two wrists
he has watches on the left hand and he
has a watch on the right hand that was
happening quite frequently in Russian
army came to Germany and they were
looting the private homes and they were
taking the watches from the people and
this guy just said well where to where
do I put all the watches I put one on my
left hand and one on my right hand but
that was not the message the Soviet Army
wanted to convey with that photo so they
were actually not so happy with this
photo and they had to change that they
had to change the hand the right hand of
the guide to a hand without a watch
because they thought that looks a little
bit more appealing you know to the
people so we stick with this and then
you know the photographer has made this
photo - this is a it was just before
entering Berlin at the at the order that
was war there was fire there was smoke
and this was a landscape with fire and
smoke and he thought well my photo is
not yet dramatic enough I think I just
put the smoke from that landscape - that
photo of the Parliament with the flag so
what you end up this is an iconic photo
which most people know very famous
symbolizing the end of the war but it's
not really authentic it has some
elements which were faked and forged so
I said observing is important if you
look at objects look at them you know
with the experts with the archaeologists
make for us look at every detail how
they look you know is it does it look
like a copy does it look like an
original is there anything strange
actually if there's anything strange
mostly you know you can assume that it's
not original then discuss it talk to
your colleagues you know make
measurements
just don't I mean this is what we do in
the museum context we are not working
alone we are always working and I refer
to this quite often as the kaleidoscopic
landscape at Yale we always work with
conservatives with curators with faculty
members who have their own perception
their own window into the question and
and it's so much better to look at all
of this together
and I want to show you one example about
the CSI which in that case really was a
crime scene investigation it is about an
art forger in Germany his name is
Wolfgang with rocky probably the most
important art forger in the history of
the country and it was the case I was
working on six years ago in Cologne 2010
2011 all these paintings are his
paintings interestingly they don't look
as if they were painted by one person
they look as if they were painted by on
the lower right phenomenology in the
middle of the blue one lahar Max Ernst
aren't we there max Paxton Heinrich come
from famous painters who all had a
different style a different technique
but at the end the story is they were
all painted by working by rocky who sold
them each I think the one which there
were little ships you know Collier the
port of call uber and Patera
allegedly four million euro this
painting many of these paintings were in
public collections so I want to show you
how that works if if something like this
comes up like ah somebody could have you
know been cheating collectors and
museums so it is a normal day you see me
in my lab with the police colleagues
from the police they bring the paintings
you see the fennel DJ on the top the RAM
take them out from the frames we have no
idea whether they are fakes or not I
mean it could be original my experience
is as soon as the police is coming to
you most probably they are not original
in almost all cases we could find
something again we look at it we we we
take the microscope we look at these
objects
carefully we should know when I'm will
not bother you with a lot of scientific
diagrams but but this one I want to show
you this is you know we are all looking
through our eyes and we see only a part
of the electromagnetic spectrum which is
around us we see between 400 and 700
nanometer this is where our you know I
is is receptive to the radiation and we
can distinguish that the blue one is the
more energy rich on the shorter
wavelengths the red one is the more
energy poor on the right us on the right
side and and this spectrum is embedded
in a whole broad you know
electromagnetic band which goes to the
infrared ray is the rather the shortwave
you know the radio waves the TV waves on
the low-energy side but to the x-rays to
roentgen you know to the to the UV rays
on the energy-rich side so we only see a
little window and I think what is the
interesting you know feature in the
conservation science lab is that we have
we have more windows we can open other
windows we can look at objects through
x-rays and I will show you an example we
can look at objects through the infrared
and we see things which which are not so
obvious to the first
I mean observation by eye and and this
is where we can then maybe get the
forger and prove something is wrong so
for example this painting Hammond pecks
max pecks time the the laying female
nude with the cat this is how it looked
you know at the front back also it
really looked good it could looked as if
it could have been from 1909 the the
forges they were even providing evidence
like this one they were sending photos
which were allegedly showing and a woman
like the the grandmother of the of the
the guy who's selling it like made maybe
with this nice you know border with the
scissors and black and white of course
and on the wall you see the painting and
you see this painting on the wall so it
pretends that this has been already in a
room in the 1930s so
it's really old a little bit strangers
if you take a close look at this photo
is that the shadow is actually on the
top of the painting which is a little
bit weird for a black-and-white photo of
the 1930s it shows that you they used
artificial light from the from the
bottom they also have the woman in the
front is not really you can't really
recognize her because that's actually
the forges wife and she didn't want to
be recognized so she they made a little
bit you know I'm readable but the worst
mistake they made was they have on the
right hand side they have this black
thing I don't unfortunately can't really
that there's a black sculpture on the
table next to the flowers this culture
is a sculpture by Wilhelm Lynbrook which
the forge aboard in 2003 and that was
really his mistake because everything
looks nice but you cannot really have a
scene from the 1930s where you have a
sculpture shown which you bought 70
years later so if we look again the
principle the visible what we see you
know we have the input in our visible
spectra we have radiation from the UV to
the IR we have a broad range of
radiation coming to the object all what
we see is between 400 and 700 nanometer
in the infrared indivisible if we look
at the IR which I want to show you we
see the reflection at higher wavelengths
at lower energy beyond 700 nanometer to
maybe 1000 1500 nanometer what you see
is I show you an example like this one I
made this for science for Saturday's
last year this is like a blue spot but
my colleagues have written something
below and then they painted it over with
the blue color if you look at this in
the IR what you see is this
because the blue is transparent for the
IR the black isn't so you all of a
sudden see something which you cannot
really see from from the visible with
your video bare eyes so let's look at
this piece the part in the painting the
feet and the IR of the feet and you see
this little thin black lines which are
called in the art world and the drawings
and the drawings are quite frequent if
an artist wants to lay out you know what
he's going to paint and make a drawing
before painting it in oil on top of it
but in this case the art curators and
the art historian said that is not the
way max Paxton painted max Paxton
painted out of his breath he painted you
know this was the 1909 this was you know
the 20th century he did it he just he
would have never used an under droid
another example are x-rays here we are
looking at the frames you see the with
the painting frame with where the canvas
is Perron and we look with x-rays on how
these frames are looking and you see the
they have these three rings this rings
which show you how the wood was growing
you know every tree has this rings
because it grows in the spring and it
doesn't grow in the winter and you have
an area of denser an area of not so
dense wood you are very familiar with
this and the distance of these rings
actually it's very characteristic for
the place that what was growing for the
age in which it was growing so you can
kind of compare the wood from one frame
to another and you see this wouldn't
just these three rings I don't even know
if that's the proper English word tree
rings but in Germany say annual annual
rings ers ringing so when you look at
the three rings of two different
paintings in this setup Iwasaki the one
painting - and the one painting for you
see that the the profit is very similar
in this case and it's also very similar
between
three and painting five what does it
tell us
I told you these artists are completely
different allegedly right the one is
from France the other one from Germany
the one from the South of France the
other one from the north of France it
tells you that strangely artists who
were painting like 20 years apart in
completely different countries have used
the same wood as the frame which is not
impossible but I would say it's only a
theoretical possibility the reality is
the forger has taken old frames and used
one for a mock sense painting and one
for phonology painting one for
anantadeva
and one for a kind recom donk and so
yeah that's eventually I can tell you
that working with rocky admitted and was
sentenced to four years in prison for
selling paintings for yeah incredible
value since the 1980s another example is
this painting this is the last CSI
example which I would like to show this
is Felix North Palm an artist which who
painted in the 1930s for this German
artist he was a Jewish artist he was
running away from the Nazi he was hiding
in the underground in Belgium painting
these paintings probably this painting
painted 1944 very shortly before the
Germans were catching him and killing
him this painting came to the Felix
Northtown Museum in osnabrück
and we did look at it with the x-rays
and this is what you see when you look
through painting with you know
high-energy x-rays in still see the ways
can you see the wave this wave on the
right you can still see that you can
still see a lot of other things but but
if you look very close you also can see
something else you can see water a lake
or the sea side you can see meadows you
can scan you see the little houses here
like farm houses in the center on the
right and the sky with clouds
so there is a painting below that
painting which in itself is not really
surprised because as I said Felix no
sperm was on the run he didn't have much
money he may have used an older painting
and painted his painting on top of it
that's possible you know especially
maybe was a boring landscape with like
houses water you want to make something
modern so yeah possible but then if you
look let's look at this black wave in
the middle between the doll and the
other ways and you see you have what is
called crackle or cracks in the paint
and these cracks if you look at them and
I'm again observing and looking at
things under the microscope they look
like this they're really white they
don't really look as if they were
hanging in a dirty room for 50 years 60
years 70 years they are too clean
they're really clean and this should
make you suspicious if a crack is there
which is so clean doesn't show any test
oh well it's always suspicious this is
another crack of the painting you can
see it's like really really clean cracks
cracks I always sign you know could be
old but they should be a little bit
dusty
I mean I'm not giving you instructions
to forge paintings right but but I'm
telling you what we look after when we
have to check whether a painting is
original or not so what we found at the
border of this painting was a green
under paint we found a paint which was
green just under the border you can see
it in the visible light and the UV light
that shines a little bit can you see
this green color very small you know
this is the place on the lower left
where we took a closer look and we we
took even a sample we took a small
scalpel a knife and we took out a small
sample from here and it's really really
small
you can see that this is the size of 250
micrometers
four pieces of this size is one
millimeter like really small and we
looked at it and I'm sorry for this but
I have to show one scientific diagram
and this in this presentation and this
is an infrared spectra spectrograph a
spectrum which shows you I mean very
simply the chemical composition of that
paint flake which was not forgetting
which was below which was below the
Felix nose from painting and this paint
is showing you that sample is the black
one on the top and the blue and the red
man on the bottoms a so-called reference
spectra for known chemical components
with called neo krill or pakora plus u
n-- acrylic so those are acrylic resins
so the painting below the painting which
was allegedly made in 1944 was painted
with an acrylic paint the acrylic paint
however was invented in the 1950s so
it's very difficult to bring a painting
from 1955 onwards below a painting from
1944 it's actually impossible so what I
want to show with this is if you look
closer if you analyze if you go into
what we think sees I can do you can
learn much more than these two guys you
know who were on a on a prf flyer for
the I think it was the Art Basel look in
art fair who said look you know you can
rely on us we sell only authentic
objects because we look carefully in
every corner not always you can you can
see it starts with the watching it
starts with observing but you have to do
analysis and we come back to to Albert
Bierstadt and you know of the nature and
the changes which you are facing
nowadays and I come to a completely
different topic sustainability
sustainable conservation and going away
now from from the conservation science
investigation the CSI
I think you may most of you may have
seen that it's about no global changes
global warming what happens with our co2
concentration in the atmosphere when I
was going when I was your age in school
the co2 content of the atmosphere was
around 300 ppm we're going up you know
we're going up we're now 350 we were
passing in in the 1980s it's going
continuously up most of this data comes
from the Mount Aloha which is a site in
I think in Hawaii and see in 89 we're
passing the 350 ppm it's not a secret we
know that the climate is changing we
know that we have global warming we know
we have more and more co2 and we have
consequences for the cultural heritage
which are related to the global climate
change unfortunately it goes very slow
we'll go until 2020 10 maybe 20 15 you
see how we go on the left-hand side in
the higher and higher with our
measurements of the co2 it looks like a
linear change now we're in the year 2003
but it's actually not
it's always a discussion I do believe in
global climate change do you believe the
temperatures are on the rise or not well
we're in 2010 I think we're soon
reaching the 400 ppm
and we look back in time what happened
actually they said the measurements
right but we can now go back what
happened in the 70s what happened in the
whole 20th century where do we come from
with our with our data and we see that
actually it doesn't right it doesn't go
yeah we see where we are
pre-industrial if we had about 200 78
200 below 300 ppm co2 and everything we
see on the right side is actually global
warming and it's your true rising what
does it mean co2 that it goes up and up
and up and actually it even goes to the
Ice Age you can see we can even go down
down down the official data from the NSF
the National Science Foundation who show
that but maybe we don't have to see all
of that just it goes up but we know that
sea levels are rising this is for
example since the 1850s the sea level in
the Battery Park in New York it's going
up we have coastal flood days going up
in the United States actually if we look
at at the sea level rise we can estimate
by 2100 a sea level rise of between one
meter and one point 8 meter and that
means just for this country 0.9 meter
means that more than 4 million people
are at the risk of inundation if we have
really 1.8 meter which is a more
pessimistic scenario more than 13
million people of United States will be
directly affected by this coastal flood
days are on the rise I want to show this
photo because this is a home destroyed
by beach erosion in Alaska in the
village of Shishmaref which is an island
reachable only by the air inhabited
since more than 4,000 years our coastal
borders will change in any case and not
only here in the US I promised you a lot
of world heritage sites this is another
one Killbuck easy money
Tanzania and the fortress is built at
the beach this is at the front line of
being destroyed by global warming and by
sea what a silly sea level rises so we
have a lot of cultural heritage in our
museums and and museums are built
everywhere a lot all over the world it's
you know I like this quote there's no me
a boom you know it's an org orgy or orgy
I don't know how to pronounce properly
and it shows you the new you know home
but forum in Berlin which is just about
to be opened in a couple of years we
have in 1972 we had approximately 24,000
museums in 8535
and and in 99 43 museums so we have
every five years we have 10% more
museums we have museums museums museums
and we have of course people visiting
the museums so tourism is definitely one
of the largest and fastest-growing
economic sectors so 9 percent of the
global GDP almost 10 percent of all the
jobs are in the tourism people come and
want to see archaeological sites and
they want to see you know museums like
here for example on my picture you go to
my picture the World Heritage Site in
Peru you have like all over tours you
can't even you know you can have the
longest sophistic of the world you will
not be able to make photo without at
least another 10 tourists on the Pittock
picture as well the international
tourism sector really is in terms of
employment behind fuels chemicals and
food
you know it's responsible for 6 percent
of global exports it's an important
factor and and this is a message I mean
I told you before about the CSI the
small samples of paintings but if you
want to preserve cultural heritage you
have to take the economics into account
you also have to know that more than 40%
of the world heritage sites still are in
Europe although we all know that you
know cultural heritage is shared by the
whole world from Asia to the South
America's seven of the top ten countries
for international tourist arrivals are
in Europe so still but I think Asia is
going to soon
take over I think France is still the
leading country with more than 80
million foreign visitors every year by
the way this is the trevi fountain a
very famous fountain in rome and you can
see how everybody wants to have a photo
of the trevi fountain was just restored
actually in October 2015 so just going
back to the US again the total economic
value of the national parks for example
is about 92 billion dollars and what I
find very encouraging and what I want to
share with you is that 95 percent of the
American public consider protecting the
national parks for future generation is
very important and 80 percent would even
pay higher federal taxes to ensure
protection and preservation of the
National Park System whether we talk
about the study of Liberty Ellis Island
the Grand Canyon you know and many many
other beautiful national parks in this
country so caring about the environment
this is a quote by David Martin caring
about the environment is a natural
extension of museums primary role of
stewardship of their collections museums
and environment go hand in hand and go
together so that's why I call
conservation management of change and
good conservation as a sustainable
management of change which means you
know it responds to the needs of our
generation but it also takes into
account the needs of a future generation
and this is all all about the people I'm
happy to share here some of the photos
of classes of courses which we made
which I made also with colleagues over
the past the people are the most
important point if it comes down to the
preservation of cultural heritage it is
actually you you know you have to decide
what you want to preserve and what not
you in the society and whether that is a
photo from Libya or from Nigeria or
recently with my colleague Paul Whitmore
of the IPC age in China and in Japan we
think museums are better suited than
other public
and it is to help to connect the local
with the global they can have a critical
role in moving the communities to more
sustainable future and this is also our
task we cannot just think about a
painting in our collection whether it's
you know fading or whether it's not
fading and whether it's you know
authentic or not authentic that's
important but we have to connect this to
the sustainable there's the
sustainability of our society and
there's one point which which is a
little bit worrisome if you look at who
is actually working in the museum's the
andrew mellon foundation made the survey
in 2015 and you see that 84 percent of
museum staff are white people you know
we talk about Universal museums we have
the Louvre the British Museum the
National Museum in Germany the
Metropolitan Museum in New York these
museums put up we are encyclopedic
Universal museums and they all run by 40
to 50 year-old white man I think that's
a problem also by the way most of the
museum staff is female I mean of course
in facilities you know handling we still
need like strongman so we have on the
left side we have you know some but if
you go to publications conservators
marketing education registrar's a lot of
women are in this field working so
actually if you look at the United
States at Europe at many countries your
preservation of cultural heritage in the
museum the conservation treatments are
mostly decided by white women at the age
of 30 to 50 is that diversity I don't
know I know that we all work together
for the preservation of cultural
heritage we all and these are colleagues
you know from the IPC age we work on
paintings we work on sculptures after
Hurricane Katrina
Paul Messier head of our lens Media Lab
was actively involved in safeguarding
and in emergency measures at in New
Orleans and in in Mississippi actually
we are working in open laboratory
settings we show what we do in the labs
we are discussing with the young people
like this one I took this photo a few
weeks ago
in Germany when we had a summit at the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs on Syrian
cultural heritage with the
director-general of UNESCO we have to
know that very often our objects which
are in the museum's have been objects of
worship they were in temples and they
just by crossing the border they turned
from an object of worship in a priceless
artifact so museums I think must focus
on cultural heritage as opposed to
culture property and they must work to
rebuild the connections between the
objects and the communities from which
they were taken and to give you one more
example from this country which I really
liked a lot from last year do you know
this mountain sorry I didn't understand
you you know the mountain it's Mount
Denali or Mount McKinley in August 2015
president Obama has renamed Mount
McKinley using his executive power to
restore an Alaskan native name with deep
cultural significance to the tallest
mountain in North America it is
important you know to understand the
story which is behind the objects
whether it's the nature whether it's the
art you know the Native Americans have
have seen for a long time
McKinley who I don't know actually I'm
German I don't know I think he was a
senator maybe from Ohio or presidential
candidate Denali is the name which they
had used for thousands and thousands of
years and returning that name back to
the mountain was very important to them
as a community and the other example
which I would like to give is a project
in Germany the Mitaka project it is a
project as you may have heard Germany
received a million refugees last winter
last year in 2015
refugees many of them came from
countries like Syria where as the war
the project Mitaka turns the museum into
a meeting point these refugees all young
refugees work at as guides in
museums they show people around in
Arabic language and I think what they do
is actually they inscribe their story on
the objects which have been so much
detached from them during the past and
through history so I think you know with
this photo which was the launching of
the social media campaign hashtag unite
for heritage in the back that into in
March 2015 I think that we are all
standing together for the preservation
of cultural heritage we're all standing
with a young or whether old or whether
in America or in the Middle East we're
all standing behind the question how to
preserve our cultural heritage
sustainably for future generations and I
think and I'm quoting here another
colleague sanchita rubella Chandra and
she's actually here for a seminar in
this week's at Yale and she had a very
impressive lecture in Montreal at the
American Institute for conservation
annual meeting in this meeting in May
and she said conservation in the 21st
century can no longer be just about
objects conservation has to be about the
people whose lives are inscribed on them
whether I just took arbitrarily two
photos I took a photo from a friend from
Sanaa Yemen Yemen
you know once called Felix arabiya happy
Arabia country where's a war going on
since 2014 by the so called Saudi Arabia
led coalition where world heritage sites
like sana and others are bombed and
people are standing in front of ruins
and the photo on the right shows also a
good friend of mine his name is Maamoun
Abdulkarim he's director-general of the
antiquities in Syria in Damascus and
he's standing in front of the ball
temple you may have heard about the city
of Palmyra
or Pandora which has been destroyed by
Isis heavily destroyed by Isis so after
the liberation of the site by the
Russians in end of March this year only
a few days later Mamoon went there and
and all you see is the particles left
the whole temple which was a
free-standing temple is in rubbles I
think we have to think about the people
who are behind that not only about this
I'm often asked mr. Seamon do you think
why do we actually think so much about
the preservation of cultural heritage
Syria is a country where two hundred
seventy two hundred eighty thousand
people were killed in the war where four
million people are on the run and many
of them in Germany and in Europe now and
you care about the stones and I'm always
saying this is not an either/or
situation this is not about stones
versus people in a disaster whether it's
an earthquake whether it's a war the
first thing people want to look after
once they are safe once they have you
know secured saved the people here their
families the children is the cultural
heritage I had in my career many times
the opportunity to see that I have been
after the earthquake in bomb in Iran in
2004 it was December 26 2003 a city of
100,000 people 30,000 killed in a minute
of an earthquake two months later there
was a survey done among the people from
from bomb and 80 percent said we want
the argue bomb the Citadel to be rebuilt
we want our cultural heritage back
people look for that if it's the flood
you know in Dresden if it's the
earthquake in Ecuador if it's or in
Nepal also last year or the war in Syria
people look for this and people actually
also want to unite for heritage and I'm
I'm very happy to to to end my
presentation here at this point because
I think our time is almost over by
reminding you that a few months ago at
Yale we had the United Nations Global
colloquium of university presidents
presidents of universities from all over
the world came secretary-general of the
United Nations Ban ki-moon spoke about
the preservation of cultural heritage
and so did the director-general of
UNESCO here in a book on culture in
crisis and we took this hashtag unite
for heritage because we think you know
that together between the cultures and
all the diversity of world's
perspectives we can make a difference in
and cultural heritage and I'm happy to
answer any questions and I'm thanking
you very much for your patience and your
attention thank you so are there
questions I can't really see feels like
in the zoo I mean I'm on the animal side
any question I don't see ah yes please
yeah thank you
well I think every repeating yes I think
the question was about question was
about in cases of large destruction like
Isis is there any you know concerted
effort to rebuild is there anything done
I would say Isis is the organization
which makes headlines on our newspapers
but it is really only a part if I would
have had more time you know to discuss
with you I would have gone into the
issue of illicit traffic of looting of
sites of bringing objects digging them
out of the ground selling them in
America in Germany in in Asia in Syria
itself Isis is responsible only for 20%
of the looting everything else goes on
in regime areas in other areas we have
and if Isis is a way somebody else will
stop in step in so Isis is not I mean
I'm kind of happy that everybody speaks
about Isis because my topic gets a lot
of attention but Isis is a minor player
we have looting going on in Cambodia and
in China and in Mali and in Peru it is a
global problem it is done on an
industrial scale and to do something
against that it's so difficult to do it
in the area where the source is because
there is civil unrest the structures are
not very well we are fighting actually
I'm fighting since 10 years to work
against illicit traffic on the demand
side to make it socially unacceptable to
buy antiquities we just passed in
Germany a law cuts a property protection
law of two two weeks ago which now
reverses the evidence you know if you
have something from Syria you have to
prove that you have it legally exported
before that it was always you could say
oh this comes from a Swiss family it has
been like the last 30 years in
Switzerland of course a very stupid
story which nobody believes but it
worked so I think this is one thing and
the other thing you have seen the photo
with all this young Syrian people at the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs in Berlin I
think you know it was very encouraging
but 250 participants at this meeting it
was all about what to do when the war in
Syria ends because the Heritage Sites
Aleppo Palmyra Damascus by the way we
should not only talk about Palmyra
because partner as an archaeological
site there are millions of people
sitting in Aleppo without water without
a roof you know we cannot forget the
people again so this is one discussion
and when I saw this young people and
like your age maybe a little bit older
many of them walking the last 800 miles
on their feet to Germany many of them
swimming through the sea from Turkey to
Greece people drowning in the
Mediterranean every day having their
brother still in the city of Italy or
Homs you know under the siege by the
government throwing Parra bombs on them
having lost family members when I saw
this young Syrian students saying you
know we are here we want to preserve
cultural heritage we are ready to step
in with UNESCO with the Germans with the
French with all parties I am optimistic
I can tell you there are plans made and
at some point Syria is going to stop the
war and and you know many countries have
seen that Germany - the Berlin was
destroyed as the capital during the war
and was rebuilt and actually the new
museum just opened in 2009 so that was
how many years 65 years after the war
things take time but you know as long as
you have the young generation with you
as long as we have a generation of
people say well I am
and I'm defending cultural heritage I
think we're on the on the good side and
we can be optimistic what do people
study in college to have a job in my
field well I can speak about myself I
studied chemistry so I started out as
this seaside person looking at little
samples you know taking faking fakes
from forgeries but also people study
anthropology archeology art history and
I'm saying especially in a city like New
Haven and the richness of the as I said
kaleidoscopic landscape of here anybody
can work with this we're now doing a
student with a student project with the
som the School of Management about the
costs of reconstruction in Syria we are
doing a project with the Yale Law School
about restitution cases of cultural
heritage so you have more and more
people looking from different angles
Divinity School from the religious
studies from the engineering you can
probably really do look from all angles
if that is you know if that is your
interest but but I personally started
out as a chemist yeah yes please what
qualifies the site to become about
heritage site that is the famous all UV
the outstanding universal value whatever
that is but a site has to have an
outstanding universal value just these
days you may have all heard about the
coup in Turkey on Friday simultaneously
and not much you know raising awareness
was the World Heritage Committee meeting
and was accepting actually a site in
Canada for the New World Heritage List
which is an Asia site on an island a new
front and a front land in Iran the loot
desert I mean there are people coming
together every year and and looking at
the World Heritage List they put Venice
for example on the red list because of
the rising sea borders they put the
mosques in Mali Janee on the red list
you know I'm talking as a German we once
lost actually the city of Dresden was on
the list of what heritage but then the
Dresden people build the bridge and then
the water Irish Committee said that
bridge is this
buying the outstanding universal value
which in that case was the view the
perspectives to the old city from the
mountains and they said you are like not
not anymore on the list so you need an
outstanding universal value in different
criteria I think there's five or six or
maybe ten key criteria so whether it's a
contribution to civilization whether
it's art an aesthetic whether it's you
know international for for bringing the
the countries and cultures together so
they're key creatures you can look this
up at UNESCO just Google UNESCO World
Heritage it's a list and then a UV
outstanding universal value yes is there
any particular culture or country which
is most at risk this is very difficult
to answer because there's a difference
between what we read in the newspaper
and what it's really happening
we may think that most of cultural
destruction is going on with war but
actually you know if you make if you
look more generally from a more remote
perspective development and agriculture
a huge factors cities like jung-geun
like Mumbai like you know which like
really develop very quickly they losing
cultural heritage at an unprecedented
speed China - by the way it's a very
it's a society developing at a very very
fast pace and a lot of culture heritage
is lost so I I can't really say I mean
we see we look at Syria we look at Libya
we look at edge of the Middle East
because of the war but you have similar
things you know South America you have
similar things here looting by the way
is also a problem for the United States
the American Southwest and the Native
American sites are heavily loaded so you
have it's it's it's really a global I
mean that's that's why I think actually
a global challenge needs a global
response so cultural heritage
preservation is an issue for everybody
across the globe that's by the way the
uniting element of the World Heritage
List 1,050 sites and and objects which
are there are still many in Europe but
you know slowly slowly we get you know
more diverse
a picture in that and that is all
binding the world together as a common
carriage as my friend my moon I showed
you the foot of Maamoun Abdulkarim he
said to me common cultural heritage is
common responsibility you know we're
sitting and we are sitting in Syria
we're defending our cultural heritage in
the first line day last of course staff
members in the war of course and they
lost lots of stuff man members through
being a becoming refugees to Europe but
they they say you know we it's our
common cultural heritage so we should
also defend it together ok I think you
had a long morning I think you're really
very much for your attentions and your
patience and I hope you enjoyed the
pathway summer program will be more for
you I'm sure Thank You Claudia for
bringing me here and was a great
pleasure